[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone
to your fantasy fire drill for week four
that's right
presented by the miller light cantenna
we got you covered as another light
always does
but we'll get to injuries we'll get to
your questions from the brf i promise
that will all be covered but
what's the news you need to know the
chiefs and the patriots
as of right now are playing on monday
night that's right
two monday night football games they
will kick off just after 7
eastern today was a clean day of testing
for the patriots and the chiefs we know
cam newton will not play we know that
already
however they will have testing rapid
testing apparently tomorrow
uh monday ahead of the game in the
morning so we'll know for sure those
guys are going to play but it looks like
you'll be able to play your chiefs
and patriots we'll of course also have
packers and the falcons the originally
scheduled monday night game
happening a little bit later on so
that's our update as i'm i'm getting a
text to see what's going on
everybody's wondering but they can wait
you are where i'm at
right now and we have our injuries to
get to the inactives are out for our
early afternoon action
let's get to those right now then we'll
get to your questions
from the brf all right so what's going
on with the
injuries here's what we know these are
all coming down a lot of it is actually
good and somewhat surprising news joe
mixon popped up on the injury report
late in the week with a chest injury
he is in i know he's been a
disappointment maybe you have him
outside of that rb1 range i understand
that but he is in
he is going to play today so hopefully
there's good news for joe mixon
with that chest injury not being a big
deal terry mclaren is in with the thigh
injury he was good not great last week
sorry about that one
excuse me he's not in the best matchup
against the baltimore ravens
so he's more of a low end mid-range wide
receiver too
moving on from mclaren uh and we go to
mike williams he is out for the chargers
today that's unfortunate for him
look echler and kelly have done a really
good job in that backfield
we know justin herbert's the guy and
he'll remain the guy i don't care what
they say
but it should be a lot of targets coming
for keenan allen today
moving on from mike williams chris
godwin we got a bunch of buccaneers
injuries to get to so chris godwin's out
we knew that already you will not see
leonard cornett today we also knew that
one already
and scottie miller is in now he's not at
100
we do know that so it's a big day coming
for mike evans
it's one of the few times i feel pretty
confident about ronald jones a solid rb2
scotty miller's more of a flex play the
hip the groin injury that's a lot to
deal with here
so he's playing but i'm not exactly
pumped to get miller
in my lineup chris carson man what a
change to the beginning of the week
he is in and carlos hyde is out
we were talking all about chris carson
hyde pops up for the injured report
he's the one that ends up being out so
as usual
chris carson is a very solid rb2
especially with hyde
out of the lineup today moving on from
the seattle backfield and move on to the
saints we knew this already
michael thomas is out jared cook is out
these are two big injuries here
for the saints but what does it mean
well of course mara continues to be busy
i still like draquan smith as well he
seems to be the man that has stepped up
in the absence
of michael thomas not a bad look for
emmanuel sanders either but it's going
to be another busy busy day
for alvin kamara moving on from the
saints here with those big injuries for
them
kareem hunt's gonna play through the
scorn injury now the browns have
admitted
it probably won't be a typical workload
which tells me instead of him being
as we always call him a top 20 locked in
rb he's more of a flex play but i do see
more touches coming for nick chubb he's
not having a bad season at all
but i think even more touches could be
coming his way against the dallas
cowboys so fire up nick chubb
with a lot of confidence today deandre
hopkins said he was going to play on
saturday
he is in today so you call him a top
five wide receiver
as you always do now christian kurt kind
of a surprise he will play today
if you were looking at andy isabella it
takes that excitement away today
i'm not really interested in playing
christian kirk this is about deandre
hopkins so that's where we are with the
arizona wide receivers moving on from
the arizona wide receivers now we get to
our late afternoon action world of that
cam akers out oh
daryl henderson fire him up enjoy the
fantasy production you get out of daryl
henderson i know i will he's already in
my lineup with confidence
and he might be putting a real lockdown
on top of that depth chart for the rams
moving on from that
uh zach moss is out that's again here
he's out for the buffalo bills they take
on the raiders today
and that's good for devin singletary's
fantasy value it gives you more
confidence to play him
as a nice rb2 in a very good
buffalo bills offense they got to be
saying that a couple of weeks ago but
here we are
henry ruggs injured edwards also injured
for the raiders here
as they move on to their game uh later
on uh look
i think hunter renfro is worth a look i
love darren wall this week i think he's
got an outside shot to be the number one
tight end for week number four
and can we get josh jacob some more
catches the man can handle it we've seen
it before
john crude give your running back some
catches from the fantasy community
we ask of you we beg of you give the man
the football a bit more so that's what's
going on with the raiders there
moving on from oakland excuse me from
vegas the eagles oh the eagles are a
mess desean jackson out outside jeffrey
not coming back
rhaegar on the ir dallas goddard on the
ir so it's going to be a busy day for
ernst it's going to be a busy day for
mile sanders and in ppr leagues i would
absolutely look
at greg ward we saw it at the end of
last season
carson wentz is kind of all over the
place right now but i think he likes
going to greg ward and guess what
he really doesn't have much of a choice
because their wide receiving core
is the worst right now in the national
football league jimmy garoppolo's out
i don't know if it matters that much
tittle's back debo's back
and nick mullins can sling it baby uh i
don't mind nick mullens as a cheap eff
play if you use your qb two and a two
quarterback lead
that's not a bad thing the niners get it
done
that's what kyle shanahan does now the
backfield
it's murky who's gonna be the next man
up you got moser looking okay
obviously you know about mckinnon you
know about jeff wilson
this could be a little annoying for a
couple of weeks as long as they have
three
backs active i think they wanted to be
mostert
but when he when he's playing with an
injury you wonder if they're going to go
with the hot hand are they going to go
who is healthiest right now so this is a
bit
murky when it comes to the niners back
though as much as you like the matchup
against the philadelphia eagles
all right moving on from that matchup
devonta adams
looks like he will play tomorrow night a
good week of practice for him now al
lazar who is looking like a waiver wire
superstar
has a core muscle injury he had the
surgery he is officially
indefinitely out for the packers so you
love devonte adams
targets are coming for him he's right up
there in the top three once again
uh mbs i don't mind valdez scandling as
a wide receiver three flex option
although obviously with adams out there
he should eat up targets as should
aaron jones getting the touches for the
green bay packers in that game as well
let's talk about the atlanta wide
receiver it looks like julio will play
it looks like calvin ridley will play we
know calvin ridley has been the dominant
force
for the atlanta falcons this year i have
him in my top five
i have julio right in that 11 12 range
so a low end wide receiver one but it
looks like both players will be out
there
against the green bay packer so those
are your injuries and
once again if you're just joining us
haven't heard the chiefs and the
patriots had a clean day of testing
um today this sunday they are scheduled
for a 705 eastern kickoff yes it's a
double main event
two games on monday night football they
will already
they are scheduled to play on monday
night right now they will have more
testing on monday so it looks safe
to play your chiefs and patriots okay
with all that being said those are your
injuries
mostly good news let's get to your
questions let's get you set up
and your lineup set for week number four
what do we got who will finish the
season with more fantasy points calvary
or dk metcalf i got both of these guys
i love having both of these guys i don't
know if it's really uh
you know this could be a difference from
a point or two
i go midly by a little bit only because
i think atlanta
is going to continue to throw the ball
like 55 times per game that's a slight
exaggeration
but i think these guys could both finish
easily inside the top ten both of them
but potentially both inside the top five
that's
how good they look right now moving on
from ridley and
metcalf that's a nice question to have
dalton schultz or austin hooper well
they play each other today
i go schultz a little bit more i have
more trust in dallas's passing game it's
a little murky there's a lot of mouth to
feed
hooper just kind of feels like a guy so
far it seems like a wasted move by the
browns
because it feels like their backfield is
the most important part of their offense
so i'll go schultz
he's a low end tight end one for week
number four moving on from that one
uh widget trade leonard fournette was
out today as we know and will fuller
who's
been banged up or doesn't get the
football for t.y hilton and darren
waller waller's the best player
of this group probably in fantasy or
reality
if i'm trading an injured leonard
fournette for the best player in the
trade i'll make that trade so yes i will
tell you
to make that trade big t moving on from
that one
should i start matt stafford or garter
minshew uh
dripping drippy i i'm gonna go stafford
he's a low end qb one of a couple spots
higher than minshew
it really makes a world of difference
that he is kenny gallaudet back there i
know the backfield's a mess
we talked about that i don't think it's
going to stop anytime soon but i'll go
uh stafford over [ __ ] you by just a
little bit the midshipmania took a hit
um will the switch to nick falls impact
chicago's skill position players
yes in a good way which is what we all
hoped would happen i know the matchup
against indy is not
ideal but there is a confidence there is
a comfort factor
i call nick foles a security blanket if
you have alan robinson it just makes you
feel better
that nick foles is playing quarterback
versus mitchell trubisky so yes
those players all see their stock on the
rise with the former super bowl
mvp under center for the chicago bears
sat gallop after getting burned in weeks
one and two yeah
that's that's the cowboys for you should
i play him over boyd today i trust
boyd moore in terms of his role with the
cincinnati bengals
could gallup go for five for 120 today
sure
you could also have three targets that's
where the cowboys are at now with lamb
and cooper with schultz with ezekiel
elliott you have all of these mouths to
feed they are throwing a lot
probably more than they want to but i
trust boyd's role more
than gallop that's just the nature of
the beast when you have that many
talented receivers all on one team
is gabriel davis a sneaky wide receiver
start this week versus the raiders yeah
a little too sneaky for me i know
brown's been banged up but
uh you know what diggs is doing i i
think it's a little too sneaky i'm not
gonna go there a name to certainly keep
uh in the back of your head though but
no not playing them today against the
raiders
uh moving on here oh greg ward just was
talking him up
ricky greg ward or randall cobb as my
wide receiver three and a half point ppr
and a half point people you know i kind
of lean towards greg ward i mean i know
cobb might be in a
little better situation overall but i
feel like ward
along with earth's is gonna get a few
more targets so i'm gonna go with greg
ward today that might not be the popular
opinion but
i'm gonna trust carson wentz to get greg
award the football uh moving on from
that one should i start ronald jones or
miles gaskin the full point ppr amazing
that we're asking this question
and both players are viable i don't say
this often
but i actually have trust in ronald
jones today with four not out there
obviously no chris godwin um it's
it's a situation where ronald jones
better get the job done so i'll go with
ronald jones
over miles gaston both good players
though today he's very happy if you get
to sit one of those guys down
uh carson wentz or justin herbert
i can't can you imagine someone saying
that to you a month ago this is what
we're gonna be and it's a real question
i'll tell you right now and i will give
you exactly where i have both of these
players
in my scoring in my my rankings just so
you know how
close this is i do have wence
one spot higher and neither player is in
my top 20 this week at quarterback that
tells you a lot right there
uh tight end toss up evan ingram or
jimmy graham where is jimmy graham come
from here you want another
live update in terms of my rankings uh i
have anger evan ingram
actually a couple spots ahead of jimmy
graham really don't love
either guy very much right now but more
injuries to the giants more opportunity
for evan ingram moving on from that
which under the radar running back
should i pick up to replace james connor
this week
i mean you could say a lot of guys are
maybe under the radar but i don't think
that's a thing anymore when it comes to
running backs if somebody has
my ability they're picked up they're out
there and on a sunday morning
i don't think you're picking a lot of
guys up unfortunately so
you would have picked up carlos hyde
maybe not maybe james white if he's out
there since he's coming back tomorrow
night but under the radar guys are not
available
on a sunday morning you gotta hit that
wave rewire early and watch waverware
weekly on tuesdays
uh is it too early to call mahomes the
greatest fantasy quarterback of all time
it's a little early weren't we calling
lamar jackson that last year mahomes is
amazing
yes let's give him a little more time
he's going to get all the accolades he
already has all the money it's a little
early to call him the greatest fantasy
quarterback of all time but he has the
skill set to be that guy
moving on from that one with chris
skywin out for today's game is scotty
miller back on the menu
uh if he was healthy i would say yeah
he'd be a really good wide receiver
three
but he's not and that gives me a little
pause so i'm not rushing to get miller
in my lineup only because he's dealing
with not one
but two injuries today so not as excited
about it moving on from that
uh is mo alley cox the next former
basketball player turns stud tight and
stuns a strong word
but i do kind of like what he's doing
rivers has connected with tight ends in
the past that guy antonio gates and
punter henry i think there's a
possibility there because
with all the injuries they have michael
pittman now hurt for the colts as well
there may be a connection here stud
might be a bit of a strong word for mo
alley cox
should i start marquez valdez
scantlinger golden tate and standard i
like mbs i know adams is going to be
back tomorrow night against the falcons
but the falcons are a very beatable team
and the giants
the giants stink let's just be honest
when in doubt go with the better
situation rogers to mbs
daniel jones and tate i think you know
where to go there mbs in your lineup
over golden k today
next up here mike davis produced in
cmc's absence
is he a set it and forget it rb1 moving
forward rb1 is a bit strong
but carolina's not good the target
should be there for
mike davis i think he's a really good
rb2 and if he gives you
rb1 production call that a bonus but if
you're picking up a guy that's stepping
in for mccaffrey and you can put them in
your lineup at least as an rb2
then yeah you're good to go so yes set
it and forget it with mike davis
preston williams or hunter renpro for
full point ppr
uh i'm leaving renfro just because of
the injuries with the raiders i don't
love either player miami seems to be
using a little bit of everybody and
they're not a great team
so i'll go hunter renfro with the
entries for the raiders at wide receiver
moving on does justin jefferson have the
highest ceiling on all the rookie wide
receivers
i mean lambs got to be in that
conversation as well maybe jefferson
just because they don't have
as many targets as many weapons as
the dallas cowboys do but i feel like
lamb from a talent standpoint has the
highest upside maybe jefferson from an
opportunity standpoint
has the highest ceiling fair question
though both really good players
should i roll with stefan diggs or adam
thielen who is benching one of these
players
how is that possible feeling i gotta go
digs diggs is rolling right now
buffalo's rolling right now i love the
connection
they have stepped it up right away
speaking of continuity not being an
issue that's the buffalo bills
with josh allen and stefan dix maybe
feeling in ppr is a little safer but i
can't sit bills right now i don't know
how you're hitting either one of those
guys you must be in a three-team league
next where do you have daryl henderson
ranked this week that giants match
is juicy yes it is where do i have him
i'll tell you exactly where i have him i
have daryl henderson at 16.
if he finished inside the top 10 this
week wouldn't shock me at all i might
even be a little too conservative
with that ranking of daryl henderson but
i feel like a couple of weeks ago
we wouldn't be talking about daryl
henderson as rb16
and we are this week yes i love them
against the giants fire them up with
confidence
next up here uh which too should i start
in a half point ppr
cd hollywood or are you well debo back
this week i'll go cd in hollywood
hollywood against washington's
okay i know the ravens haven't hit those
strides
like we wanted them to from last season
but it's early it's week four
uh go with the first two there is this
the week
canyon drake finally lives up
to his adp and i'm putting my head down
because
it should happen right i mean i it's got
to happen they're playing carolina you
start your running backs against
carolina with confidence so
i have him at rb8 this week which is
probably a little higher than his adp so
yes i say it happens this week
it's better kenyon drake's got a
beatable panther defense let's go kenyan
drake
moving on from that one should i start
joshua kelly or antonio gibson rb2 with
sanders 40.
kelly's getting the touches i told you
he would there is a nice role for him
in conjunction with what the chargers
have with austin eckler i like this role
for kelly
especially in standard scoring you're
playing kelly over gibson i don't like
gibson today
against the ravens all right are we
firing up
our burkheads this week or is it a
fool's errand to predict the patriots rv
touches
yeah with james white back and all that
it's tough
uh if you picked him up this week it was
the right call i think you play him as a
flex and you hope for the best
this this is what we deal with this is
the bellatrix there's no
dominant back for the patriots they're
all flexes at the absolute best
next uh which quarterback should i start
watson or
burrow there's another one can you
imagine us asking that question a month
ago
oh watson or burrow all right i got
watson at eight i got burrow at 10.
there you go joe burrow already in my
top ten but watson a couple spots higher
what a nice spot to be in with two top
10 quarterbacks on your roster
next is jameson crowder the most
underrated fantasy player in the league
he's on the jet so i can't say that and
he's missed time this year
he's a nice player in an awful situation
no he's not the most underrated fantasy
player and
i probably should give you an answer to
that question but it's not jameson
crowder i can tell you that
uh better flex play and half point ppr
you know what it might be darren waller
by the way i still think he gets love as
one of the best titans in the nfl
russell gage or emmanuel sanders julio
and ridley going to play
i'm going to go sanders just because of
the injuries with jared cook and michael
thomas out i don't love either guy this
week
all right here we go so i started ty
hiltner john brown i'm going to go
hilton
by a little bit i i feel like kilt's
gonna get it back on track this week
starting this week i don't think he's
ever gonna live up to the old
expectations of ty hilton but i will
tell you to play hilton
uh over brown this week all right next
one go djs
but which one more for chart
i got to go dj more i like shark
but they're using everybody there i mean
that's where things are at right now
with jacksfield plus james robinson has
become a very important part of their
offense so i'll go
i'll go more i i feel pretty good about
that uh going against um
arizona today next up
where did cedric wilson come from
speaking of dallas guys
uh and is he worth an ad look i i
he could have no catches today that's
where dallas is at they have a wealth of
talent there
i think he only got involved more late
in that game there's there was targets
to be had
i don't think you can assume that's
coming every week just too many mouths
to feed to
add another receiver from that team uh
which back to your
preferred rest of the season joe mixon
or kareem hunt look hunt with a groin
injury worries me
eileen mixon i'm not gonna go overboard
with mix and love
hun is still the number two back in his
honest team it's still nick chubb's show
so eileen mixon
look he got off to a slow start last
year and finished off strong so i'm
gonna go mix and i feel better about
that one
all right why haven't the jets fired
adam gase yet freeze in
i thought it was coming after grizzly
night football i really did i don't
think it's gonna fix darnold
i think the jets need a lot of things to
fix their team
i don't know what they're waiting for
get a head start on the coaching search
because
the answer is not adam case i feel you
jeff's fans i feel you
uh robert tonyan has scored in
back-to-back weeks is he a top 10 tight
end play the rest of the season
touchdowns are fickle
they can be random you know maybe you
say because lizard is not out there and
he's out and definitely
i'm not a believer in that i think it's
gonna kind of be random when it comes to
those touches outside of adam's mbs and
of course
aaron jones next uh t
higgins stock is on the rise could it be
a decent flex play versus the jags yeah
i do think he's a sneaky place but
getting looks he's been getting the
snaps
um i kind of like where he's at right
now i like
the fantasy value of that team dare i
say kind of well defined i love
well-defined options
next up what does it say about deandre
swift
that ap got 20 plus carries in week 3.
look we need to look at this in a vacuum
adrian peterson is still a good running
guy
we cannot overlook that fact am i taking
the ball out of adrian peterson's hands
when he's always better when he gets
more touches probably not
is it really annoying if you have the
andre swift yes
but you have to read what's happening we
could have drafted john dre slip to be
that guy
the bottom line is he is not he is bench
fodder
at best on your fantasy team whether we
like it or not
that's reality next will having alec
camaro's numbers come back to earth
once michael thomas returns some injury
probably in terms of targets he's
getting a ridiculous target share
out of necessity he can also handle it
does he go from rb1 to rb5
uh possibly that's when you drafted him
anyway right three four five right in
that range
it's not going to crush him but right
now his ceiling is unbelievably high so
it'll just be
high when michael thomas comes back next
a couple more
after getting exposed on monday night
football is lamar jackson
still a must start in fantasy
i'm here i'm baffled that we're asking
about lamar jackson's fantasy value
in week four after he won the mvp
last year tranquilo relax
not everybody lights it up every single
week you'd like it to happen
some people have off weeks he's gonna be
fine yes lamar jackson
is a must start i can't believe i just
have to answer that question
one more can we finish on a high note
please name one thing that's prettier
than a russell wilson default i think
this jacket's nice i don't know if you
call it pretty you can call it pretty i
think it's a nice jacket
but the russell wilson depaul going to
lock it going to metcalf
having metcalf in my lineup i love it i
think seattle
other than the chiefs might be the most
fun name to watch right now and i was
not always a big russell wilson
fan but right now he's got a stake to be
the number one quarterback in fantasy
or reality that's how pretty it is so no
nothing is prettier right now
than a russell wilson default and
hopefully nothing is prettier
than your starting lineup in your league
it's the winning lineup it's the one
that's going to take you
to a week four win hopefully i helped
you get there
don't forget hit us up on the brf with
your questions and come back with us on
tuesday for waiver wire weekly
we'll get it fixed we'll figure out
what's going on with the injuries
hopefully not too many more
and the look ahead on thursday so that's
where you're at for week four
i'll be back with you next sunday noon
eastern
for your fantasy fire drill presented by
the miller like canton i'm matt camp
good luck everybody
[Music]
ready
[Music]
foreign